how did he save your life
um i was
making fights for a kid who was in the
whose father was in the mob and they had
spent money on this white heavyweight
i won't say his name he was terrible he
was absolutely horrible
and um
i had been doing business down south
with a veteran matchmaker
and who who knew his business guy who
really understood
what he was doing so this kid was going
to turn pro
this mob kid and we brought him to a
safe environ
where under the radar you know nobody
because we wanted a first round knockout
and i was given money to give to this
matchmaker
which i did and i said okay so it's one
round
it's one round and he said um
yeah no problem at all we're at the
fights
and i don't i patrick to this day i
don't know how
this happened but just before the fight
i had this intuition
where i went into the loser's dressing
room the loser was clearly a kid who
couldn't fight
i mean i could see that right away and i
was talking to his his
handlers manager i don't know who the
guy was
and i said so he knows what to do
and he said what do you mean he says you
mean
does he know how to fight i said no i
can tell you he doesn't know how to
fight
but you know what's going to happen
right and he goes i said how much did
you get paid for this fight
he goes you know we get paid 80 bucks a
round
four round fight i said okay
so i go back into the the audience
because the new york guys are all there
and i said look there's a little there's
a little issue here um
and i still remember the kid's father
gets up
he puts his arm around me and he makes
sure that i see he's got a gun
and he says well you're gonna handle it
and i said yeah i'm going to handle it
and he says okay how bad language can i
use here whatever you want
yeah it's fine he said if we don't get
what we want
we're going to kill you we'll kill that
[ __ ]
who stole our money and we're gonna kill
the fighter
and everybody else we can think of and
these are serious guys he whispers this
to you
yeah and he's a boss at the time he's
not a boss but he's you know
connected he's con yeah he's connected
and he's and he's the
you know he's got the fighter so he and
he's the son of a son of somebody
somebody powerful in the mind
and they've already they're already
spending a lot of money on this kid's
career and this kid cannot fight at all
not not even a little bit and he's
petrified because this is his first pro
fight
so i go back to the dressing room and
i said kid you're going to lose this
fight you're going to get knocked out in
the first round
and he says i can't do it.
he's a southern kid he said i can't do
it because
my parents are in the audience my
sisters and brothers and i said
we're gonna all be dead in the next 10
minutes
and it gets weirder he says he's from
new york
he's going to kill me anyway i said no
no no you don't understand
he's in his dressing room throwing up
right now
if you even look at him he's going to
faint i know you can't fight
but he doesn't know that so
you're going to lose and then the
matchmaker comes in
and i said to the matchmaker what did
you do he goes this kid can't fight at
all
i said that's not what you got paid to
do you got paid to fix the fight
fix the fight no but it's going to be a
one-round fight he can't fight
i said you took his money and
i said give me all the money you've got
everything you've got he goes well
some of this is my money i don't want
your money anymore
it's this kid's money and then i said
and i said to the kid i'm not going to
tell you his name either
but i had a brainstorm i said look you
don't have to fight under your
own name nobody cares make up
and i'm just going to say like his name
is
[Music]
you know billy alexander which is not i
said make up a name he goes and he's
crying at this point
he's actually crying he goes uh bobby
alexander and i said no no billy see
bobby alexander sounds quite a bit like
billy alexander
you know and he'd say well bobby
alexander you know
it's okay we'll take care of it and i
said to the
matchmaker
you got to give this kid under his own
name four wins
so he starts his pro career at 4-0 this
this is you know
so he's okay we'll do that and i take
the kid
out into the parking lot and there are
still
people straggling in because this is you
know early this is one of the first this
is in fact the opener
of the fight i said put your hands up
now i'm not a fighter and you know i was
a lot younger then but i wasn't a
fighter then either
and i hit the kid in the mouth as hard
as i can
and then i hit him in the stomach as
hard as i can and then i hit him in the
mouth as hard as i can and he starts
he gets bloody lip and i say to the kid
the guy who's
kind of the towel comes in right then
that's what happens and i said
don't you throw a punch back don't you
dare throw a punch back this is how it
is
and i said you throw the towel in high
right up to the middle of the ring and
you yell something as you throw it in
which he did the fight lasted 17 seconds
and it looked
sensational and the mob guys
they love me again everything is good
and i think
okay everybody got what they wanted
that's good business
and then they say we need to talk to
this matchmaker
and i said you don't need to talk to
this matchmaker
you got exactly what you wanted he's
scared to death he didn't make a dime
he lost his own money it's done
just think business just you're telling
this to the mob
mobster yeah this is business you know
if something had happened it would be
all
you know i could see the the the wisdom
of doing something about it but there's
nothing to be done
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye